here like rats without peer that's valid
outlast
have a buddy I'm a cute little bunny
have a cute bunny I like you buddy
how about you buddy ah you have a
beautiful smile I won every sub I do
quite unique yep best hiding spot ever
I play prop punch [ __ ] alrighty
then
that's just what were we doing why me
Gabe why me why me that's all right
toilets oh I don't like to cite it Oh
God
gosh darn it oh oh oh well I'll be
darned Tollett it's just you and me he
that's all right watch stop talking to
me toilet I'm tired I was shut up what
they do for fun Internet's missed it's a
toilet he talked to me he talked to me
he talked to me he's not dead
why are you Billy so huge when someone
is sensitive about their body
how did they do that the double bluff
he'll be like hey I bet I can he's like
I'm sure there was no one in here that's
so weird not be like ha ha ha ha it's
like psych all right we're gonna Yolo
our way through this oh oh well this
would have saved me a lot of [ __ ]
height no you can you get up there sir I
don't have time for you and your
[ __ ] this it's like beginning of an
SS video hi and in the end of it out
that okay I'm saying
anyway it's [ __ ] intense man is only
as much in my heart can handle this is
okay don't he's [ __ ] dead no doubt of
that I'm sorry bro you gotta go hey
beautiful
oh this is where it started that's the
funny coincidence all right we made it
out of lime huh sorry about that bro
nothing personal or anything
[Music]
yes coming I'm coming I'm not sure what
to make out of that you're strictly get
from the recreation all right it's
upwards
okay recreational it's over here hi we
can do this we came so far I kind of uh
check in here hello
oh they had like a pool table and
everything oh we were supposed to go
here of course alrighty then oh okay I'm
supposed to go here ah
shit's intense
actually nothing is happening Ben I need
to drink some water I'm sorry I usually
don't record as long all right Oh night
why don't we just leave are you afraid
that people are gonna judge you because
you don't have Yahtzee fingers anymore
I'm sure Martha and Lanie will play
Yahtzee with you anyway
I can throw the dice for you man oh
there is someone playing oh oh he sees
me a boy abortion that's what you should
have not
I don't you dare judge me that [ __ ] you
see that look he gave me ain't nobody
give me that look all right what do we
got this excellent yeah uh-huh all right
and we go here what is this I'm not
gonna regret going here
well this audience is well what a dead
crowd all right
can I play the piano or can i [ __ ] the
piano
either way I'm intrigued okay oh not so
cool not so cool
but okay can I sit next to you I'm gonna
make out there was no alteration to the
footage in June of 1943 you recorded
three instances of spontaneous bleeding
a half-a-dozen test subjects began to
develop brain tumors yes all the
Rorschach images tumors were pure late
it killed her
can you explain why the results could
not be reproduced in the United States I
have my theories my homeland in those
years it's impossible to understand the
things we've helped what we believe
ecstatic region English let's please is
capable of extraordinary things you're
saying the experiment needed the
proximity to this to overwhelming
madness only a test subject with
witnessed enough horror was capable of
activating the engine do you believe
your test subjects achieve something
supernatural no do you think that they
contacted something supernatural
nothing is supernatural then what was it
you said project well writer was a
gateway a gateway to what my [ __ ] but
twist tell us come on come on hey you
can't finish can you finish it there I'm
cool are they gonna use me to open my
mind am i nothing all right
Oh [ __ ] course follow their blood they
said [ __ ] lockers hey you're coming
out oh oh because Oh wrong one
okay [ __ ] that I can't I can't
potentially nothing him what are you a
golf club ball yep
I nail that sentence [ __ ] all right we
climb right no there are vents though oh
we can just go up here
wonderful hey chair what that is vlog
hiiiii mama mia pizza here why are you
doing this why you know this why you not
warn me the phone batteries in the
mornings kinda dinero dare better man
why you keep this clothes on me come on
it has to be what the [ __ ] oh we can go
in here now excelsior I'll excellent
yeah
is it idiot la da da da da da da dadad
up better laughs Oh Dada Dada
great party y'all I'll be back next year
alright this is where we make our jump
yeah yeah [ __ ] you see that [ __ ]
son I don't even show that I'm harder I
mean action movies okay I got to show my
tits on the screen no all right we have
the key to the third floor now wine all
right I guess we're going back
what what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate your
wait wait
uh-oh Megan down from day let's swear to
God I jump down for Tommy who is it
who's out there
[Music]
where is he
the Frank
[Music]
hmm there's got to be quiet
you know seriously why gain got out out
out out out out of that out of that
outta hmm oh I know where we're supposed
to go I'm an idiot
okay when the pain is gone it's time to
make a thong song
get it we did it
high-five okay all right
today so with me again ten the [ __ ] are
you doing I'm sick of you and your
[ __ ] and you're not gonna stay away
from me getting in that room I don't you
still care I regret this sorry sorry
something I mean you're just cuz you
have a penis flopping around doesn't
mean I'm scared are you all right god
[Applause]
damn okay brother
kizomba I'll say that commuter there
lambda n de la familia refer Blin
brûléed ah
oh yes sir anus arsenic star a quick rub
rather do that feast
Mike
[Music]